I've designed another class, that I call the Simulation class, that puts all
the information together. It keeps a list of all the cars in the simulation and
all of the people. I'm giving you a method to read in all of those data, and
that's not the part that I'm most interested right now, so we'll glance right
past it. Now the simulation has two phases. In the first phase one loads all
the passengers into the cars and in the second phase we drive all the cars
until they have arrived. So go ahead and implement this method, what you
going to have to do is for each passenger you want to find a car that can hold
it, that means you need a loop over all the cars until one of them says yes,
this passenger can be added